nasser merci d'être là vous avez
carrément joué dans le flou oui mais
vous êtes dégoûtés aujourd'hui par
l'image que le stim véhicule voilà à
mercredi vous avez pu rencontrer
emmanuel macron qui est le président et
nasser vous avez un seul but montrer une
autre image des quartiers et donnez
votre vérité sur la cité regarder on va
regarder votre échange avec emmanuel
macron regarde
l'âge de 13 ans et on sortait de ma
chambre on se rappelait en traiter de
sale arabe fait d'enlever 3000 euros
l'année et à la maison j'étais grand
chose pour pouvoir tester cause à
l'heure actuelle je suis au chômage
depuis depuis septembre et c'est très
compliqué et pour la une qualification
j'ai une qualification jockey
professionnel bien sûr je détiens ma
carte ça fait maintenant depuis 2015 que
j'y tiens cette carte est que les que
c'est très compliqué dans le jour j'ai
gagné la première course à marseille on
est allé féliciter la deuxième parce que
n'a pas d'origine mais les mains en tout
cas mabrouk le président et c'est
démonter
il avait un buffet la hollande il
a tu fais la même scène avec françois
hollande à
tapas macro de
cfoot est interpellé le président comme
ça il était sympa avec toi était très
sympa oui il est sympa plus que sympa
parce que déjà mettre un pied dans notre
cité c'est déjà ça vous la touchez que
le président vienne bien sûr comme à ce
qu'un geste fort pour sûr c'est un geste
fort c'est quand même le chef de l'état
sait c'est le président de la république
et déjà c'est compliqué d'avoir quelques
dirigeants de ce pays c'est quoi les
retours sur le sur le voyage des manuels
mcqueen et les retours sont bons les
gens étaient contents de le voir bien
sûr qu'on était payées des jeunes comme
quoi il était heureux bien sûr bien sûr
on était tous très heureux de sa venue
chez nous parce que c'est un engagement
et ce changement qui est sûrement
proches comment comment commence à
organiser la rencontre ce que ça c'est
important les gens veulent savoir
comment s'organise la rencontre avec
emmanuel macron il savait qu'il allait
parler ou pas du tout le mal qu'on
savait qu'elle aimait parler d'accord
j'ai la mafia s'est passé en fait tu as
dit dieu avec l'association des femmes
de base qui nous suit depuis longtemps
avec madame séri bialli qui me suis
aussi depuis longtemps galy qu'on
embrasse formidable série super c'est
sans elle on se régale
bon heureusement qu'elles sont là pour
nous épauler au quotidien comme je
disais et donc le présence avec de la
halle avoir un échange avec toi n'est
sûr il a été sympa retail will a été
très sympa il a été très à l'écouté je
pense que c'était pas une écoute
factice mais une écoute sincère et alors
toi y'a un truc qui te gêne c'est que ce
film back nord ce film déjà la première
question qu'il faut se poser c'est park
lille a été fait à part qu'il a été fait
par la police nationale c'est le film de
la police nationale non ça met en avant
la police nationale n'est pas la réalité
de toi tu as tu trouves que tout ce qui
est dit dans le film c'est fou il a la
quasi majeure partie c'est faux mais
alors seigneur d'ailleurs on a on a déjà
sur le but on a fait beaucoup de choses
déjà
juste voilà on a vu beaucoup de
chaussures basses et on a vu aussi un
truc c'est que avant que le président
harry il paraît que vous avez
complètement fait le ménage à marseille
parce que les gens disent c'est quoi
l'histoire
dès lors que le président fait tout le
monde a su le président allait venir
chez nous ddd des services
d'hygiène privé même et pas publics sont
venus nettoyer nos ils ne font pas ça
avant de faire il n'ya pas le président
ne le font pas ça non non c'est surtout
juste les zemmouris passe alors la lévée
paysagiste donc
c'est pourquoi ils sont dix à le
président terrain que c'est comme quand
ta mère elle va arriver dans ta chambre
je vois pas ça mais c'est vrai tu dis de
la mer alary bon c'est bon et maman est
vendu en pack ans de retour elle c'est
ça qui était choquant parce que il faut
qu'il ya quelques à prayssas chef de
l'état il n'existe quoi on va vraiment
sinon vous êtes laissés pour compte mais
sinon télé c'est pourtant depuis même
sur les images de bfm tv il ya quand
même des de nos poubelles qui sont un
peu plein alors que le matin c'était un
câble carrément en abondance alors on va
parler du film et de ce film qui crée
énormément polémique bat nord est il
raciste c'est parti c'est à dire la
partie
guillaume genton oui en moi je pense que
malheureusement ce genre de film qui
contribuent à alimenter tous les clichés
qu'on a ce talent on va dire il ya donc
sur les toits les téléspecteurs
justement puisqu'on voit si on voit le
résumé puisqu'on parle de racisme de
manière un peu caricaturale ces trois
flics dont deux blancs qui passent leur
temps en fait à se faire tabasser par
des racailles dans des cités qui sont
pourquoi de blanc ni tout blanc
non mais karim les clous il est
d'origine de mai non mais je parlais de
la santé non mais je sais je non mais je
parle de racisme puisqu'on parle de
clichés racistes et ça que je dis moi je
super six du tout qui passent leur temps
à se faire taper dessus par des
racailles qui sont représentés par des
noirs et des arabes c'est ça les clichés
racistes que ça véhicule dans ce film-là
et malheureusement je pense que c'est
très loin de la réalité parce que certes
dans les quartiers il ya une minorité on
est d'accord c'est une fiction mais ça
donne une image vaut pardon je ne
connais pas les quartiers marseille bat
à cause de ce film c'est l'image que
j'en viens à l'ordre attendu
alors attendez attendez deux petites
secondes s'il vous plaît je vais
remettre tout ça en place tout seul
alors vous avez vous décidé à vous et
vous avez beau dire vous avez beau dire
que c'est tous ce film vous avez beau
dire que c'est une fiction je suis
désolé les mecs gd mais j'ai des mecs
qui sont sortis du film qui m'ont dit
t'as vu ce qui se passe à marseille
l'histoire c'est ce serait la réalité
qui était projeté à ce film c'est sa
réalité elle n'est pas là la réalité
c'est que ce film il a été il a été fait
par le policier en question qui
rackettaient la cité qui frappe les les
habitats légers leur part certes la
police n'est pas la belle tout rose mais
c'est l'effet j'étais sur les plateaux
de tournage avait le policier avec le
sucre et britt et qu'on s'était lui qui
faisait
pression vous parlez pas de sens attendu
vers des j'ai lu et entendu tout ce qui
se disait et s'écrivait sur ce film et
vous l'avez vu j'ai décidé de ne pas y
aller parce que ce film véhicule une
idéologie raciste à voile ne stigmatise
allait y aller et être otage de cette
idéologie est un film politique c'est un
film d'extrême droite c'est un film qui
stigmatise les quartiers il appelle
l'effet passé ils étaient passés pour
des repères de voyous on ne parle pas de
toutes les actions qui se font dans les
métiers encore une fois on a des gens
qui habitent dans les greniers qui n'y
sont pour rien qu'ils sont confrontés à
une vidéo ici qui tente de lutter ce
film pour moi je vous le dis franchement
il est nauséabond alors il ya un
journaliste irlandais lors du festival
de cannes qui a vu le film louis et qui
a dit qu'il était inadmissible ce genre
de film qui ça lui avait donné envie de
voter pour marine le pen que c'était un
film de propagande pour al hawa marine
le pen chose en plus de 90 minutes alors
il y en a plein qui dit ça
c'est pour ça qu'on pose le débat ce
soir pour vous pourquoi c'est vrai c'est
le film de marine le pen bon alors elle
a même twitté dessus elle est
coproductrice ou pas
logiquement intéressé c'est sûr je suis
désolé mais c'est ça le problème parce
que quand les gens d'extrême droite
cautionne ce film du conte dit le film
est raciste et d'ex endroit parce qu'il
est cautionnée par des ans mais de
quelqu'un ne cautionnera filiation à
l'extrême ce sens je suis désolé s'est
inspiré 10h15 albert des quartiers alors
il me restait reddition mais alors s'il
te plaît nasser pourquoi tu pourrais
dire assiste une douce voix donne nous
ton histoire dis nous ce qu'ils
racontent le film pour le téléspectateur
pour toi pour moi en fait de ce que je
connais de la cité de ce que je connais
de nos quartiers de ce que je connais de
ses policiers au moins il est il est
extrêmement raciste parce que je vois
des deux côtés mais pourquoi avoir
accepté de jouer et donc ses assesseurs
mais parce que je pensais qu'ils
allaient véhiculer notre image que je
crois qu est ce qu on a vendu on m'a dit
que ça allait la vérité de l'histoire de
bac nord est bien d'accord mecs
connaissez ce sport alors on va rappeler
l'histoire s'il vous plaît j'aimerais
quelqu'un rappelle l'histoire de ce film
gilles verdez ou
bernard montiel oui c'est l'histoire
s'ils sont un vrai d'un scandale qui a
eu lieu en 2012 ou 18 policiers ont été
condamnés de toute façon parce qu'il y
avait non seulement alors c'était vol
c'était vols et extorsion en bande
organisée c'est à dire qu ils
rackettaient en plus les dealers ils
rackettaient tout le monde et ce dès du
fric est il sauvé un peu la paix du
karabakh et par les wayuu etc voilà ça
c'est une histoire vraie c'était en 2012
et ils ont été condamnés donc et le film
est vraiment tirer de ça j'ai vu le film
et je trouve formidable formidable et
moi des gens qui habitent là-bas et
d'autres qui habite dans d'autres
quartiers autour de paris m'ont dit non
c'est très proche de la pêche tout en
ayant vu le film et en ayant et on subit
au quotidien ce que je subis en sortant
du film j'ai réussi à me dire [ __ ] les
policiers en chie quoi
je vais pas parlé une seule fois de
médaillon sur un mythe a conscience
aussi d'affaires la conscience d'un sert
aussi qu'il ya des politiques mais dieu
sait combien
américain extrêmement bas oui s'il sait
ça métier que que personne n'a envie de
vivre au quotidien parce que la police
sait pas c'est que je veux dire c'est
pas des robots quoi mais je ne citais
c'est pas trop
tôt jean messia oui
moi je les ai vus alors moi j'ai eu la
chance mais pour comme beaucoup ici
d'avoir vu il ya 16 ans le film la haine
enfin si vous rappeler de ça ce film et
ce film était avait une halte motif
qu'ils étaient
jusqu'ici tout va bien mais l'important
n'est pas la chute c'est l'atterrissage
avec ce film là on a atterri alors je
comprends si vous voulez non non on a
atterri dans la réalité alors je trouve
dans l'arène dans les jeux conseil
national je comprends que le réel est
difficile à avaler pour toute une
catégorie
politique et jean qui s'est acharnée à
le nid je te met d'accord mais enfin
c'est la vérité voilà c'est ce qui se
passe dans l'est dans les quartiers il
faut l'accepter alors évidemment ça
dérange une certaine gauche elle pendant
des années on a compté jusqu'à non mais
parce que vous avez vu le film raconté
aux téléspectateurs ce qui est raconté
dans sim ce qui se passe dans le
quartier dit le nom même bernard montiel
a parfaitement imparfait mais moi j'ai
pas envie
je l'aimé mais je suis passé avec la
barre attendez je suis pas sortie avec
l'impression que les flics que les flics
avaient été était uniquement des avez vu
le film d'accord et je suis sorti avec
l'impression que les flics étaient aussi
des coupables moment je trouve que le
film au contraire assez équilibré non
mais mais là ce dont on parle enfin les
lesquinois route et les plus le profil
que vous voyez dans les films que dans
le film d'accord ce qui s'y passe la
manière dont la police est accueilli
dans certains quartiers c'est exactement
la réalité même parfois c'est en dessous
de la réalité alors je comprends que ça
gêne parce qu'évidemment dans une
idéologie qui promeut le vivre ensemble
qui veut faire de ces de ses quartiers
d'été des zones de brassage bienheureux
etc je comprends que ça puisse gêner
mais le pôle le le truc c'est qu'à un
moment le réel pour pouvoir le traiter
il faut aussi le voit à 25 ans du cinéma
là bas tout le monde aux valeurs
saisonnières et nasser nasser bien vous
le réel s quand j'ai vu le réel j'ai
grandi j'ai grandi dans des quartiers
dans l'est de la france un bon élément
d'équité à bien sans mais ces deux jeux
je suis un rythme mais je suppose mais
depuis les choses se sont arrangées
dewind criminalité le plus élevé est-ce
que vous avez mis un pied chez nous non
mais ce que vous avez vu je me suis dis
jamais d'accord mais c'est un simple
trait attendiez vous savez moi ça m'a
certainement de danse rap et par la
providence écart à faire dans ces
quartiers s'ils voulaient y avait des
cités ouvrières ya 40 ou 50 ans dans
lesquelles il y avait d immigration
européenne et on en constate est pas si
vous voulez les la criminalité la
violence était pas gangréné par ce tout
ce dont on voit de que convoi a dans la
réalité et dans ce film bizarrement
c'est pas le problème ce n'est pas les
quartiers c'est pas un problème
d'immeubles même si ça contribue mais
c'est pas qu'un problème d'immeubles
qu'un problème de construire 5 06 des
populations et à un moment il faut le
dire il y à certains les migrants 5 y
participent
et là parce que vous avez illustré tout
le propos lui vit dans les quartiers
nord de marseille il vous explique ce
qu'est la réalité vous nous pour aider
les rescapés au vieillissement vous
expliquer et bien songé parce qu'il
s'est fait virer le tournage arrêtez
vous expliquez vous la liste vous dites
les populations jeunes tout ça mais je
viens des
conflits quand je ne jalouse et là je
vous ai jamais entendu et c'est louis
beau diable je vous ai jamais entendu
parler par exemple du merveilleux film
les misérables qui a été primé aux
oscars primé au festival de cannes
c'est parce qu'on en parle à moi je
n'aurais pas parlé d'un drame c'est quoi
la différence c'est que dans les
misérables ou même dans le film de kery
james là bas les gens des cités ils ont
une vie ils ont une famille il ya des
enjeux pour veut dans ce film ces gens
sont juste des méchants
maintenant messieurs c'est à dire que
ces gens seraient juste des voyous des
criminels
on parle énormément 17 et par les rôles
de drogue pour pas la criminalité c'est
la règle est souvent de faire des films
sur les sites est revenue à elle nommée
aux artistes français viennent de là-bas
il ya plainte associés et ce film est
juste en train de montrer que les cités
ce serait uniquement le rassemblement de
dealers et de criminels alors qu'en vrai
c'est
ce
qui sera dit au président je le dis
qu'il fallait un avenir meilleur où ces
jeunes de shit et qu'il fallait plus de
moyens qu'il fallait un accompagnement
que ce soit financier ou éducatif parce
que sans l'éducation de l'état ces
jeunes y suivre une certaine a décidé de
tout a dit que d'être dans les cités j
habitais c'est très dur personne a
décidé d habiter dans et connaissez les
comédiens quand même moi j'ai fait
plusieurs plusieurs tournages d'accord
oui vous a pas dit aller chercher du
travail c'est de l'autre côté de la rue
comme il l'a fait récemment avec un
autre un autre jeune sarah alors et est
toujours en train de stigmatiser assez
cotisé jeudi simple je veux je veux je
suis aidé dans le point que les deux les
deux les deux pointures du président tu
viens te la résidence quand il lui
dirait du tout jeune quand il a en face
une vie
je dis
ça mais venger parce qu'il a été viré du
temps devenu berger parce que j'étais
une armature oui parce que vous étiez
allé jusqu'au bout vous auriez c'est ce
que vous avez dit par des oui c'est ce
que j'ai dit oui en quelle année j'ai
été viré du tournage moi non
donc oui d'accord mais il ya quand même
plein de gens qui dans ce cas là vous
êtes un peu vénère pour la saison
suivante chine elle a été coupée vous
étiez allé voir le film en espérant vous
voir qu'est-ce que moussa l'appareil ce
que je sais maintenant que je peux
vénère si j'habite parti n'a fini que je
me voyais pas non plus
c'est bête de dieu ça serait parfait ça
normal là c'est normal qu'il y ait des
gens qui disent assure malgré des gens
qui disent ça mais c'est pas la réalité
encore une fois l'argent qui bloque et
sur mes fils cadet et c'était en réalité
dans ce cadre un énorme rôle dans le
film et que le film ha ton qu'on connaît
est-ce que tout est ce que ton règne la
même et non
j'aurais pas eu la même attitude de la
merci mais certainement comme tout le
monde donc tu auras
ta vérité elle varie en fonction de
la vérité je
vous la donne si fort était mon métier
simplement je regrette vraiment ok
d'accord alors oui c'est abusé là lui
vient pour dire mais attendez là moi et
mes frères et là c'est pas la réalité
rem et fierté à mener sa politique nous
avons fait venir je vais peut-être que
tu dit pas la vérité parce que ça et
saisir et du film et de vous cette
série c'est quoi le message me dire oui
mais pour ce héros vous savez de sa
bière du coin ça vient jean messia
arrêté dernier de créer que dit ce même
attisé les peignoirs et lisa mais
arrêtez de donner du grand mère qui le
décrit des biscuits
ça raconte l'histoire c'est que matisse
où
vous êtes je lui répondais
m'appelle travail et d'avoir une tête
d'arabe ça dérange pas du tout pressé de
dire ah non c'est toi qui es raciste
tags la santé dr et énervé nantes est un
raciste passer dessus car si l'on dit
pas on est tous nous avons à présent on
n'est pas toujours c'est de la même
façon excuses mais
j'entre
dans les gens qui s'y soumet du caire
dont les jours des gens qui dit oui mais
moi je n'ai fait mais jeudi elle vous
avez jeudi avec la
the man est permis même sur les
policiers jeux les jeux les caillasses
moi je suis légitime pape veut tuer les
si je trafique pas de la drogue d'accord
il n'y avait pas d'étrangers on est à
deux personnes d'origine étrangère et je
dis je dis pas ça pas tout ce que je dis
qu'il y à cerner qu'un papier assez
c'est l'immigration qui pose problème
mais les voyais alors ça il voulait voir
ailleurs vous votre secret vous n'êtes
pas pays en a d'autres y en a d'autres
qui s'assigne il s'assigne s'ils
travaillent leurs impôts sachez tout a
changé mais je sens bien
ça tu fais mais je vous dis les deux
vainqueurs les deux il ya des règles ou
vous écouter ou bien vous sortez je vous
le dis je m'en fous c'est que c'est
clair quand on dit au stop c'est scop
gilles verdez les discours de jean
messia sûr il ya deux manières de
d'immigrés il ya le bon immigrés le
mauvais immigrés bien le beau français
le bauhb et feront baisser on vient se
poser non non ça c'est non mais sans dec
je vénère peut pas laisser passer ça
j'en messia ya des poubelles placées ou
pas mais arrêter il n'y a pas de mauvais
français
taper sur bon ou mauvais transfert il ya
des gens bien ses sauts et des mauvais
la région mais d arrêter ce n'est pas
une question d'immigration d'origine je
dis ça j'ai dit ces photos ou encore une
fois encore une fois vous voulez fait
sur et la france et vous engouffrer dans
les flammes avec un discours d'extrême
droite bien sûr voilà c'est reconnaissez
vous poserez l'aï vu
je comprends pas vos réactions notamment
la tienne parce que les flics sont pas
mises alors comment vous la pluie quand
vous appelez une affaire florian c'est
pas ça non c'est oui c'est lui pardonne
en a parlé pendant trois heures en plus
mais lellouche moussavi s'était brouillé
avec une réalité qui était montré je
comprendrais rien accusé samedi flics ne
sont pas montrés comme des ans plus
précisément ils ont aimé je suis là pour
le démontrer puisque je vis au quotidien
alors qu'ils n'ont pas dans le film
c'est pas du tout ça ce n'est pas la
réalité mais ce que vous avez vu avec
emmanuel macron ce n'est pas la réalité
je faria pâtissait de police au coach
nous protéger nous les habitants y'a pas
tous ces tuyaux pour l'arrivée du
président mais quelque part oui d'accord
quelques percées ce alors c'est normal
jean louis saez et bien sûr on voudrait
qu'un film soit documenté un film c'est
un parti pris voilà ça va être une
histoire on aurait pu faire un autre
film sur marseille qui a raconté une
autre histoire la voilà c'est un film si
ça ne vous plaît pas c'est autre chose
quant à stigmatiser je suis désolé oui
je connais pas beaucoup
stigmatise beaucoup aussi tu parles à la
serbie en mon frère avec ses terrains on
est à nous et nos frères et cetera ça
c'est pas une façon séparée des
doutes et frère ben parce que j'appelais
loger les gens frère je fêtais à bonbons
gamongirls pas mon frère c'est pas
pareil
c'est la sélection
ça les mesures ci seydoux frère ben
voila voila il visite le pen mélodies
fait en effet il apparaît que frère quoi
frérot c'est pas pareil mais c'est pas
pareil non c'est inutile de série mais
ce qu'on peut pas faire un débat sur
celle
[Rires]
là les chéris tracteur cia fabrique
sébastien patrick c'est pas ça qui va
arriver dans l'instant je veux que des
gens efficaces
sophie
je comprends tout à fait ce que dit
nasser c'est à dire que ça reflète pas
la vie des quartiers mais c'est pas le
sait pas le film le film c'est une
histoire de démantèlement d'un réseau de
dealers l'eau qu'est ce qu'on montre au
monde des policiers et des dealers et
c'est le film il ya une scène très sympa
justement on montre la vie des quartiers
avec le petit qui à un moment donné se
retrouve dans la voiture des flics il
lui met un sont sympas et le mélo mais
c'est la lru
non mais c'est très lourd édition du
club rue de ne pas que tout de suite je
peux finir ma phrase que font mes
policiers les policiers dans les
quartiers comme ça ils agissent pour les
gens des quartiers non parce que là la
mère de famille qui rentre avec ses
gosses dans la cage d'escalier c'est ce
qu'à l'entrée du bar déjà se découvrir
le film et qui dealent bas si on le voit
dans les sables du sommet sont en train
de nettoyer l'itc ce que justement
nigeria 2 point même où les anciens 10h
après trust a tué ses dealers toi t'as
pas de problème mais bien sûr quand je
dirige ici ce sont des gens est ce que
tu sais qui te regardent à la télé non
mais vraiment
d autres oui mais lui aussi dit qu'il
est bon
les gens il faut line et la cac mais
séoul a regardé d'autres films et vous
verrez que donnait la réalité ces gens
sont des sincères et tant d'autres que
ça vous plaise ou non je veux c'est jean
louis s'est passé depuis deux ans mais
respectez les vraiment
on arrête donc ça suffit pas toujours du
les jeunes de cité qui veulent pas s'en
sortir ou qui qui sont là dedans moi non
j'ai pas fait assez long mais je suis je
suis là aussi pour dire mais là c'est à
ce que je vois que des réussites et
qu'ils ont un talent qu'ils ont un
métier qu'ils avaient sur menace est
repassé à ce que je peux te dire un truc
là voilà on est on est dans un film je
vais te dire eux et ils veulent que le
fils mark ils veulent faire du
sensationnalisme aussi ils veulent faire
un truc voilà ce qu'ils en voient
forcément fait forcément et j'espère que
le réalisateur est que le mec qui a fait
deux films se savent que dans l'iss et
il y avait quatre jeunes il y en a qui
sont un dealer ou qui sont voilà qui se
passe des très belles choses aussi dans
les quartiers mais forcément son parti
pris dans le film il faut que ça
bastonne à chaque fois donc il n'a pas
pu montrer ça et il n'a pas choisi de le
montrer n'est sûr mais ça reflète pas ça
en fait on ne fait pas un de ses
adversaires le scandale policier qui a
eu bien sûr comme ça c'est rien ça oui
mais attention mais c'est sûr qu'à
rentrer sans rien la réalité une aubaine
alors je vais vous dire ça reflète une
partie
oui mais le problème c'est pourquoi il
ya des pourquoi il ya plein de gens
aussi qui disent qu'ils sont très
touchées est très peiné par celui
pourquoi parce que quand les gens
sortent de ce livre j'ai eu des potes
qui m'ont appelé qui m'ont dit t'as vu
bac nord t'as vu ta vu ce qui se passe
dans les quartiers et on n'est pas au
courant a donc les mecs tu le prennes
poire jamais nommé parce que ça fait là
bas ce type aux crises y du film et je
regrette ce que j'ai en michel marie
vente soit tombée dans un piège et
bernard disait sa part d'une histoire
vraie mais l'histoire vraie et les
bidons et le film est doublement soirée
qu'un projet d'accord avec vous mais
s'arrête à turin si l'on mâche dévasté
condé normal centimes c'est caricatural
policiers ne sont pas ouvertes du film
cyril on nous fait croire que c'était
une histoire vraie c'est vrai c'est ça
l'hypocrisie du film c'est ça le
scandale du film comme si on avait dit
c'est une fiction rien n'est vrai mais
là on dit c'est une histoire vraie
regarder sa
guimbarde à moutier mais évidemment que
c'est une histoire vraie ça a été
condamnée jugés condamnés et bon non
mais il va falloir l'adaption veut aussi
de l'actuelle histoire vraie sur vous
n'allez pas dire que vous êtes un
glandeur pendant 90 minutes
car cette histoire personne est épargné
ni les jeunes de ces quartiers ce que je
clique c'est très important ils sont où
il dépasse ils sont illégaux avec des
méthodes doute personne n'est content du
père celle des copains du fil parce que
là il montre vraiment la violence des
dit il ceux qui sont contents que je
suis sûr de voir un spectacle un film
c'est des claques à spectacle on
suit en fait l'histoire des flics on
suit pas l'histoire de la cité c'est
l'histoire des flics oui mais bon donc
c'est normal et on va prochainement
reprochera d'accord on me les donner
quand on sort du film et moi j'ai des
gens qui sont sorties des films aux
dîmes salue ce qu'ils font les filles
mary ce typhon les cotes et a vu ce
qu'ils font les mecs de cités
si le personnage principal et les
acteurs n'ont pas beau la vie pour leur
rôle d'arrêter ce que match mal c'est
l'angle qui ai choisi l'angle c'est
normal dans une fiction tu as de
l'empathie si tu joues un serial killer
ton doigt pâtit pour le personnage que
tu joues là ils jouent des flics ripoux
donc on a de l'empathie pour d'ex écrit
poucave alors qu'on se dit bien que des
flics ripoux série tout donc c'est pas
on n'a pas à avoir de l'empathie pour
eux